These are the space cadets,...
...young engineers with a job that's quite literally out of this world.
They've turned their dreams of working in space into a down-to-earth career.
I love working in the Mars Rover mission because it is very cool.
And I think most people in the world would agree that working on a mission...
...that's ultimately going to trundle around on Mars is pretty cool.
The coolest thing about this job is that you are driving a spacecraft...
...which is in another planet.
I mean, how cool is that?
Just, I think, five years ago, my biggest dream would be,...
...was actually, just to touch something that was going to space.
And now I'm working with instruments that are going to space.
It's unbelievable.